bon les avis les sujets n'arrête pas sur
cyril hahn enquête exclusive sur m6 lui
a été consacrée regarder cyril hanouna
ce nom ne vous dit peut-être rien
pourtant il a forcément influé un jour
sur votre vie ayrault
keira flibustiers nous avons recueillies
anonymement des témoignages anonymes de
personnes qui l'ont croisé anonymement
tout en préservant leur anonymat une
enquête choc mais anonyme signée jean
louis mythomane et basile boli
l'assassinât de kennedy
la crise des 'subprimes' the cover
derrière tous ces événements se cachant
seul fautif cyril hanouna et c'est à des
huit que nous nous sommes rendus pour
recueillir des témoignages inventés de
source sûre db je devais assurer la
sécurité des soldats rêver ça dégénère
il a commencé à le taper être rêver tant
d'années déjà lancée qu pour protéger je
me souviens comme si c'était hier
on immeubles étaient en feu cyril
hanouna passé par là par hasard dans la
rue il a soufflé sur l'immeuble et l
incendie s'est éteint le jour de la
sextape de valbuena j croisade ou nac
acheter un caméscope chez darty donc
voilà pour moi il est forcément
responsable de quelque chose les gens
disent que je suis l'homme le plus
intelligent de tous les temps mais en
fait c'est juste parce que j'étais assis
à côté de six réunions sciences nat et
que skopje sur lui la voilà je suis
arrivé dans l'équipe de touche pas à mon
poste il ya deux ans j'ai croisé seringe
était stérile à l'époque
la poser sa main sur mon slip et mad
love toi et enfants et depuis j'ai
quatre enfants et c'est vraiment pris
bonnes vérités je suis pas du tout le
premier homme à marcher sur la lune
quand on est arrivé il y avait déjà si
reina il devrait former avec un drapeau
de la tunisie est un thé à la menthe et
une habitude demandé si on voulait un
couscous